selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation, nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah direktur teknis untuk pendidikan
di IBM Quantum. ini adalah pelajaran kesembilan dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran pertama di unit ketiga yang membahas tentang
formulasi umum informasi kuantum. sampai sekarang kita sudah menggunakan formulasi sederhana dari
informasi kuantum di mana keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan oleh vektor kompleks yang memiliki Norm Euclidean sama dengan
satu. sebaliknya, dalam formulasi umum informasi kuantum, keadaan kuantum direpresentasikan oleh
matriks dari jenis tertentu yang dikenal sebagai density matrices. pelajaran pertama unit ini berfokus pada density matrices secara khusus
dan kita akan mempelajari apa itu dan bagaimana cara kerjanya seiring berjalannya pelajaran. density matrices sangat
berguna dan menawarkan berbagai keuntungan yang akan kita bahas. mereka memungkinkan kita untuk merepresentasikan
kelas keadaan yang lebih luas daripada yang bisa dilakukan oleh vektor keadaan kuantum, termasuk keadaan sistem yang telah terpengaruh oleh noise misalnya, serta
pemilihan acak keadaan kuantum. kita juga akan melihat Block sphere yang memberi kita cara geometris yang sangat bagus
dan sederhana untuk memikirkan keadaan qubit dan kita akan melihat bagaimana hubungannya dengan density matrices dengan cara yang
cukup luar biasa melalui Pauli matrices. akhirnya kita akan membahas density matrices dalam konteks beberapa
sistem dan khususnya kita akan melihat bagaimana mereka memungkinkan kita untuk menggambarkan keadaan kuantum dari sistem yang dilihat secara terpisah bahkan ketika
mereka berkorelasi dengan sistem lain dan itu termasuk kemungkinan bahwa mereka terjerat dengan sistem lain. ini adalah hal penting yang
perlu bisa dilakukan dan tidak mudah dilakukan dalam formulasi sederhana informasi kuantum. berikut adalah gambaran umum
pelajaran ini. kita akan mulai dengan dasar-dasar density matrices termasuk definisi yang relevan dan beberapa contoh, dan kita akan
membahas bagaimana hubungannya dengan vektor keadaan kuantum. kita kemudian akan membicarakan kombinasi konveks dari density matrices atau dengan
kata lain apa yang terjadi ketika kita mengambil rata-rata tertimbang dari density matrices. kita akan mulai dengan
contoh spesifik dari yang disebut completely mixed state. kita akan melihat bagaimana keadaan probabilistik klasik dapat dilihat sebagai
kasus khusus dari density matrices dan kita akan membahas bagaimana teorema spektral dari aljabar linear berperan dalam
konteks ini. bagian ketiga dari pelajaran ini membahas Block sphere yang menyediakan cara geometris untuk melihat keadaan
qubit tunggal seperti yang saya sebutkan di awal pelajaran dan di bagian keempat pelajaran kita akan membicarakan bagaimana density matrices bekerja untuk beberapa
sistem. kita akan membahas product states dan correlated states dari berbagai jenis termasuk entangled states serta
gagasan tentang reduced state yang merupakan deskripsi density Matrix dari keadaan bagian terisolasi dari sistem majemuk
yang dapat dihitung menggunakan operasi yang dikenal sebagai partial Trace. sebelum kita masuk ke konten teknis pelajaran itu sendiri,
ada baiknya kita meluangkan beberapa saat untuk memotivasi penggunaan density matrices menggunakan formulasi sederhana
informasi kuantum yang tidak melibatkan density matrices. kita bisa menggambarkan algoritma kuantum seperti
algoritma faktorisasi Shor misalnya tanpa kesulitan apapun. jadi mengapa kita harus repot-repot dengan density matrices
atau formulasi umum informasi kuantum ini sama sekali? nah ada beberapa alasan. pertama, density matrices
merepresentasikan kelas keadaan kuantum yang lebih luas daripada vektor keadaan kuantum, termasuk keadaan kuantum di mana kita memiliki ketidakpastian atau
Keacakan. ini penting ketika kita ingin memodelkan efek noise pada komputasi kuantum misalnya.
kedua, menggunakan density matrices kita bisa menggambarkan keadaan kuantum dari bagian terisolasi sistem majemuk seperti
keadaan sistem yang terjerat dengan sistem lain yang mungkin sesaat kita pilih untuk diabaikan seperti yang saya sebutkan di awal
pelajaran. ini tidak mudah atau secara alami dilakukan dalam formulasi sederhana informasi
kuantum. alasan ketiga adalah ketika kita menggunakan density matrices informasi klasik sebenarnya muncul sebagai
kasus khusus. jadi alih-alih memiliki analogi antara keadaan probabilistik dan operasi di
satu sisi dan vektor keadaan kuantum dan operasi uniter di sisi lain, kita memiliki informasi kuantum dan klasik
yang dideskripsikan bersama dalam satu kerangka matematika tunggal yang hampir sangat penting untuk studi matematika
informasi kuantum. jadi jika kamu serius ingin memahami informasi kuantum di level matematika, sangat
disarankan untuk mempelajari density matrices. mari kita mulai dengan definisi density
matrices. untuk keperluan definisi, misalkan X adalah sebuah sistem dan sigma adalah himpunan keadaan klasiknya, dan ingat bahwa
ketika kita menggunakan terminologi tersebut, asumsi kita adalah bahwa Sigma berhingga dan tidak kosong, dan seperti biasa kita bisa memilih
nama yang berbeda jika mau. sebuah density Matrix yang menggambarkan keadaan sistem X adalah matriks yang memiliki entri
bilangan kompleks di mana baris dan kolomnya telah ditempatkan sesuai dengan himpunan keadaan klasiknya, dan untuk lebih jelas
korespondensinya sama untuk baris maupun kolom secara bersamaan. ini berarti bahwa density
matrices selalu merupakan matriks persegi dan selain menjadi persegi ada beberapa kondisi yang harus
dipenuhi dan kita akan membahasnya sebentar lagi. orang biasanya menggunakan huruf Yunani kecil tertentu untuk menamai density
matrices. rho sering menjadi pilihan pertama dan pilihan umum lainnya termasuk sigma kecil dan tau yang ditampilkan di
layar. ini hanya konvensi tapi seperti biasa konvensi semacam ini membantu karena membuat hal-hal lebih
mudah dikenali. dan sekarang mari kita bahas kondisi atau persyaratan yang harus dipenuhi oleh density matrices agar menjadi
density matrices yang valid. ada dua kondisi dan yang akan saya lakukan adalah pertama-tama mencantumkannya saja
kemudian saya akan membahas lebih detail apa artinya. kondisi pertama adalah bahwa density
matrices harus memiliki trace satuan atau dengan kata lain Trace sama dengan satu, dan kondisi kedua adalah bahwa
density matrices harus positive semi-definite, dan dalam kedua kasus kita memiliki cara simbolis yang ringkas untuk mengekspresikan
kedua kondisi tersebut yang muncul di layar. sekarang mari saya bahas dua kondisi tersebut lebih detail.
kondisi pertama mengacu pada trace yang merupakan fungsi yang sangat penting dan didefinisikan untuk semua matriks persegi
dan itu hanyalah jumlah dari entri diagonal dan berikut adalah persamaan yang mengekspresikan hal tersebut
secara eksplisit. sekarang ada banyak hal yang bisa dikatakan tentang trace dan mengapa ini penting tapi untuk sekarang mari kita perhatikan saja
satu sifat dasar yang sangat sederhana yaitu bahwa itu adalah fungsi linear. sifat-sifat trace lainnya akan muncul dan akan kita bahas ketika
diperlukan. tapi untuk tetap fokus pada density matrices mari kita lanjutkan ke persyaratan kedua yaitu bahwa
density matrices adalah positive semi-definite. ini juga merupakan konsep penting yang muncul dalam banyak pengaturan dalam
WEBVTT
fisika, kimia, optimasi, machine learning, dan subjek lainnya, dan bisa diekspresikan dalam beberapa cara yang berbeda tapi
ekuivalen. satu cara untuk mengekspresikannya adalah dengan mengatakan bahwa matriks rho adalah positive semi-definite jika ada matriks M
sehingga rho sama dengan M dagger kali M, dan ternyata tidak masalah apakah kita menuntut bahwa M sendiri adalah
matriks persegi atau jika kita menghapus batasan tersebut. cara lain untuk mengekspresikan apa artinya sebuah matriks rho menjadi positive
semi-definite adalah dengan mengatakan bahwa rho adalah Hermitian yang berarti sama dengan conjugate transpose-nya sendiri dan semua
nilai eigennya adalah bilangan real non-negatif. secara umum matriks Hermitian hanya bisa
memiliki nilai eigen bilangan real tapi bisa negatif, tapi jika kita menyertakan batasan tambahan bahwa tidak ada
nilai eigen yang bisa negatif kita mendapatkan matriks positive semi-definite. dan omong-omong jika kamu diberikan
sebuah matriks dan ingin tahu apakah itu positive semi-definite maka kamu bisa menentukannya menggunakan karakterisasi ini. cukup mudah untuk
memeriksa apakah suatu matriks Hermitian, itu adalah sesuatu yang bisa langsung dilihat. lebih sulit untuk menghitung
nilai eigennya tapi itu adalah sesuatu yang tidak terlalu sulit dilakukan dengan komputer karena ada algoritma yang sangat efisien untuk melakukan
itu. dan karakterisasi terakhir yang akan saya sebutkan meskipun ada yang lainnya adalah untuk setiap vektor kolom s yang memiliki
jumlah entri yang sesuai dengan jumlah baris dan jumlah kolom rho, pertidaksamaan yang ditampilkan di
layar adalah benar. dalam kata-kata, bra-s kali rho kali ket-s harus merupakan bilangan real
non-negatif. tidak jelas omong-omong bahwa karakterisasi ini semua ekuivalen tapi memang demikian. dan perlu dicatat secara eksplisit bahwa
notasi yang biasa kita gunakan untuk menunjukkan bahwa matriks rho adalah positive semi-definite terlihat seperti rho lebih besar dari
atau sama dengan nol tapi ini hanya notasi singkatan dan itu tidak secara harfiah berarti bahwa rho lebih besar dari
atau sama dengan nol. rho adalah matriks jadi itu tidak masuk akal dan itu tidak berarti
bahwa setiap entri dari rho lebih besar dari atau sama dengan nol. khususnya ada matriks
positive semi-definite yang entrinya tidak semuanya non-negatif dan ada matriks yang entrinya semua
non-negatif tapi tidak positive semi-definite. ide di balik notasi ini adalah bahwa matriks positive semi-definite
adalah seperti analog matriks dari bilangan real non-negatif tapi ini hanya notasi dan artinya adalah
tepat seperti yang sudah kita bahas. sekarang mari kita lihat beberapa contoh dimulai dengan contoh
matriks positive semi-definite. sebenarnya cukup mudah untuk secara acak menghasilkan contoh
matriks positive semi-definite hanya dengan memilih matriks M secara sembarang dan kemudian menghitung M dagger kali
M. misalnya, berikut adalah matriks M yang tidak terlalu istimewa dan sebenarnya saya
membuat matriks ini secara acak dengan memilih secara independen bagian real dan imajiner dari entri sebagai bilangan bulat antara negatif 9 dan positif
9. jadi pola atau struktur apapun di sini murni kebetulan. dengan mengalikan
conjugate transpose dari M ke M kita mendapatkan matriks ini di sini yang karenanya positive
semi-definite. tentu ada batasan seberapa banyak wawasan yang bisa kita peroleh dari contoh acak tapi itu memperlihatkan beberapa
fitur yang umum untuk matriks positive semi-definite secara lebih umum. khususnya kamu akan memperhatikan
bahwa entri diagonal yang berarti yang berada di sepanjang garis dari kiri atas ke kanan bawah semuanya merupakan bilangan real
non-negatif dan lebih jauh lagi entri di luar diagonal entah bagaimana tidak terlalu besar dibandingkan dengan diagonal
yang bersesuaian yang berarti yang berada di baris yang sama dan yang berada di kolom yang sama dengan entri di luar diagonal apapun yang kita lihat.
namun ada lebih banyak hal dari ini dan penting untuk menyadari bahwa positive semi-definite adalah
sifat matriks secara keseluruhan dan bukan hanya kondisi pada entri individual. jadi itulah contoh
matriks positive semi-definite dan kamu bisa sangat mudah menghasilkan contoh lain melalui metodologi yang serupa.
sekarang mari kita lihat beberapa contoh density matrices di mana selain kondisi positive semidefinite kita juga memiliki bahwa trace-nya adalah
sama dengan satu. berikut adalah beberapa contoh density matrices 2x2. trace-nya sama dengan
satu dalam keempat kasus dan kita juga bisa melihat bahwa ini adalah matriks Hermitian. jadi menggunakan karakterisasi kedua dari
matriks positive semi-definite sebelumnya, yang perlu kita periksa adalah bahwa semua nilai eigennya non-negatif.
saya biarkan itu untuk kamu periksa jika mau. untuk matriks 2x2 tidak terlalu sulit untuk menghitung nilai eigen dengan tangan
tapi kamu juga bisa meminta komputer untuk melakukannya. misalnya kamu bisa menggunakan fungsi eigVal dalam paket aljabar linear
untuk python. kita juga bisa mendapatkan density matrix hanya dengan mengambil sembarang
matriks positive semi-definite yang tidak nol dan membaginya dengan trace-nya. misalnya berikut adalah density matrix yang kita dapatkan dengan
membagi contoh yang baru saja kita lihat beberapa saat lalu dengan Trace-nya. membagi dengan trace seperti ini
akan selalu mempertahankan sifat positive semi-definite dan kita pasti akan mendapatkan matriks yang memiliki Trace sama dengan satu karena
trace adalah fungsi linear. itu hanya sedikit koleksi contoh dan kita akan melihat lebih banyak seiring
pelajaran berlanjut. selanjutnya kita meluangkan beberapa saat untuk membahas interpretasi atau
makna intuitif dari density matrices. hal pertama yang perlu diakui adalah bahwa mungkin terasa sedikit tidak biasa
bahwa kita merepresentasikan keadaan sistem dengan matriks daripada vektor. sebaliknya dalam formulasi sederhana
informasi kuantum kita menggunakan vektor untuk merepresentasikan keadaan sedangkan matriks khususnya matriks uniter
merepresentasikan aksi atau operasi. ini hanya cara matematika bekerja dan meskipun kamu bisa
selalu memikirkan matriks sebagai menggambarkan pemetaan linear kita biasanya tidak mengasosiasikan makna intuitif langsung
dengan pemetaan linear yang terkait dengan density matrix tertentu. meskipun begitu fakta bahwa
density matrices memang berupa matriks ternyata menjadi aspek yang sangat penting dari mereka dan kita akan melihat
itu saat kita terus maju. tapi untuk secara singkat menyebutkan satu contoh untuk sekarang, nilai eigen dari density matrix tertentu
ternyata sangat penting karena mereka menggambarkan seberapa banyak Keacakan atau ketidakpastian yang melekat pada keadaan
yang digambarkan oleh density matrix tersebut. cara berbeda untuk memikirkan density matrices di level intuitif
berfokus pada entri matriks ini. ingat bahwa baris dan Kolom dari density matrices ditempatkan
sesuai dengan keadaan klasik dari sistem apapun yang kita bicarakan. jadi untuk setiap entri kita memiliki satu
WEBVTT
keadaan klasik yang sesuai dengan baris entri tersebut dan satu keadaan klasik yang sesuai dengan kolom entri
tersebut. untuk entri diagonal, dua keadaan klasik tersebut adalah keadaan yang sama dan itulah mengapa entri diagonal
istimewa dan satu cara kita bisa menginterpretasikan entri diagonal adalah bahwa mereka adalah probabilitas dan khususnya mereka adalah
probabilitas bahwa keadaan klasik yang sesuai akan muncul jika kita melakukan pengukuran basis standar
pada sistem yang keadaan kuantumnya kita gambarkan. untuk entri di luar diagonal di sisi lain kita memiliki satu keadaan klasik yang sesuai dengan baris
entri tersebut dan keadaan klasik yang berbeda yang sesuai dengan kolom entri tersebut dan secara informal
entri-entri ini menggambarkan sejauh mana dua keadaan klasik ini berada dalam superposisi kuantum serta
fase relatif di antara keduanya. itu mungkin lebih masuk akal seiring pelajaran berlanjut dan kita melihat lebih
dekat beberapa contoh spesifik dan detailnya mungkin belum jelas saat ini tapi jangan biarkan itu mengganggumu
ya. ini cukup informal dan hanya dimaksudkan sebagai ide intuitif yang bisa kamu simpan di belakang
pikiran. selanjutnya kita akan melihat hubungan antara density matrices dan vektor keadaan kuantum yang merupakan vektor kolom
dengan Norm Euclidean sama dengan satu. hanya untuk mengingat definisi matematika, misalkan kita memiliki
vektor keadaan kuantum s yang merepresentasikan keadaan suatu sistem tertentu. density Matrix yang merepresentasikan keadaan
kuantum yang sama diberikan oleh ket-psi kali bra-psi seperti yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. untuk menjelaskan hal ini, indeks dari psi
sesuai dengan cara tertentu dengan keadaan klasik dari sistem apapun yang kita bicarakan dan itu akan menjadi persis korespondensi yang sama yang kita miliki antara
baris dan Kolom dari density matrix kita dan keadaan klasik sistem. jika kita bayangkan ada n
keadaan klasik sistem dan kita memikirkan vektor kolom dan baris sebagai matriks maka ket-psi adalah matriks N kali 1
dan bra-psi adalah matriks 1 kali n. jadi ketika kita melakukan perkalian kita mendapatkan matriks N kali n.
ini akan selalu menjadi matriks positive semi-definite berdasarkan bentuknya dan juga akan memiliki Trace sama dengan
satu karena s adalah vektor satuan dan kita akan melihat itu lebih detail
sebentar lagi. keadaan kuantum yang direpresentasikan oleh density matrices dalam bentuk ini disebut Pure
States. berikut adalah beberapa contoh. pertama mari kita pertimbangkan keadaan
ini yang mirip dengan plus State kecuali bahwa entri yang sesuai dengan keadaan klasik satu adalah
imajiner. jika kita menghitung conjugate transpose kita akan mendapatkan tanda minus karena conjugate kompleks dari i adalah
minus i dan jika kita melakukan perkalian kita akan mendapatkan matriks yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. itu Hermitian sebagaimana bisa
kita lihat langsung hanya dengan melihatnya dan kebetulan memiliki satu nilai eigen sama dengan satu dan satu nilai eigen sama dengan
nol. jadi itu positive semi-definite dan Trace-nya sama dengan satu. jadi itu adalah density matrix seperti
yang diharapkan. kita bisa menghitung density matrices yang sesuai dengan basis standar dan basis plus minus dengan cara yang serupa dan density matrices tersebut
ditampilkan di sini. dan berikut adalah satu contoh lagi dari vektor keadaan kuantum yang kebetulan
muncul jauh di pelajaran pertama seri ini dan jika kita menghitung conjugate transpose kemudian mengalikan
kita akan mendapatkan density matrix yang ditampilkan di sini. sekali lagi itu Hermitian dan memiliki
Trace sama dengan satu dan jika kamu menghitung nilai eigennya kamu akan menemukan bahwa sekali lagi ia memiliki satu nilai eigen sama dengan satu dan satu
nilai eigen sama dengan nol. dan omong-omong itu adalah karakteristik umum dari semua Pure States. mereka selalu memiliki satu nilai eigen
sama dengan satu dan sisa nilai eigennya semuanya nol. secara umum untuk vektor keadaan kuantum
yang sepenuhnya sembarang s dengan jumlah entri berapa pun jika kita mengalikan ket-psi ke bra-psi kita akan mendapatkan
density matrix yang terlihat seperti ini. perhatikan khususnya bahwa entri diagonal selalu merupakan salah satu dari
entri s yang dikalikan dengan conjugate kompleksnya sendiri yang bisa kita ekspresikan secara alternatif sebagai nilai absolut kuadrat dari entri tersebut dan ini adalah
salah satu cara untuk melihat bahwa trace akan selalu sama dengan satu. ini juga konsisten dengan catatan yang saya buat sebelumnya dalam pelajaran tentang
entri diagonal dari density matrix yang memberi tahu kita apa probabilitasnya untuk melihat setiap keadaan klasik yang mungkin
jika kita melakukan pengukuran basis standar. dan satu catatan terakhir di sana
tidak ada masalah mengenai fase global untuk density matrices. dua keadaan kuantum identik jika dan hanya jika density
matrices mereka sama. khususnya misalkan kita memiliki dua vektor keadaan kuantum s dan fi yang
ekuivalen hingga fase global yang berarti kita bisa mengekspresikan salah satunya, misalnya fi, sebagai yang lainnya dikalikan
dengan beberapa bilangan kompleks pada lingkaran satuan. jika kita menghitung representasi density matrix dari fi maka yang akan
kita temukan adalah bahwa faktor fase global dikalikan dengan conjugate kompleksnya sendiri dan itu memberi kita satu sehingga
secara efektif menghilang dan kita tersisa dengan density matrix yang persis sama yang kita dapatkan dari s. jadi itu semacam
bonus kecil yang menyenangkan dan secara lebih umum tidak ada masalah mengenai ekuivalensi hingga fase global sama sekali ketika kita
bekerja dengan density matrices. itu pada dasarnya hanya degenerasi yang ada ketika kita menggunakan vektor keadaan kuantum daripada
density matrices untuk merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum. density matrices memiliki sifat utama yaitu kombinasi konveks
dari density matrices merepresentasikan pemilihan probabilistik atau acak dari keadaan
kuantum. cara lain mengatakannya adalah bahwa density matrices bisa dirata-ratakan bersama dengan cara yang bermakna yang merupakan
sesuatu yang tidak bisa kita lakukan dengan vektor keadaan kuantum. untuk menjelaskan ini lebih detail mari kita mulai dengan situasi di mana
kita memiliki dua density matrices rho dan sigma yang merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum dari suatu sistem. mari kita bayangkan bahwa
sistem tersebut disiapkan dalam keadaan rho dengan probabilitas P untuk beberapa pilihan P antara nol dan satu, dan jika tidak
sistem disiapkan dalam keadaan Sigma. misalnya mungkin p adalah 1/2 sehingga
kita bisa membayangkan bahwa seseorang melempar koin yang adil dan jika kepalanya mereka melakukan beberapa proses yang meninggalkan sistem dalam
keadaan rho dan jika tidak jika koin menunjukkan ekor mereka melakukan proses berbeda yang meninggalkan sistem dalam
keadaan Sigma. pertanyaannya sekarang adalah apa keadaan sistem tersebut dan untuk lebih jelas
kita tertarik pada keadaan sistem secara terpisah mengabaikan informasi lain yang mungkin ada tentang
persiapan mana yang dilakukan. misalnya bayangkan kita tidak memiliki akses ke koin atau
memori siapapun yang melakukan persiapan keadaan tersebut dan jawabannya adalah bahwa itu hanyalah rata-rata tertimbang dari dua density
WEBVTT
matrices yaitu P kali rho ditambah 1 minus P kali Sigma. omong-omong ini sepenuhnya
analog dengan apa yang kita miliki jika rho dan sigma bukan density matrices melainkan vektor probabilitas
yang merepresentasikan keadaan probabilistik. jadi ini bukan sesuatu yang mengejutkan atau misterius melainkan adalah sesuatu
yang mungkin sudah familiar dari teori probabilitas. kita melakukan jenis rata-rata ini setiap saat ketika kita menghitung probabilitas dan memikirkan
pemilihan acak klasik dan intinya adalah bahwa ini juga bekerja untuk density matrices. tapi perhatikan bahwa itu tidak
bekerja untuk vektor keadaan kuantum. yaitu kamu umumnya tidak bisa merata-ratakan dua vektor keadaan
kuantum seperti ini dan berharap mendapatkan vektor keadaan kuantum yang valid dan jika kamu mencoba biasanya kamu akan mendapatkan vektor yang
tidak memiliki Norm Euclidean sama dengan satu. dengan density matrices namun rata-rata tertimbang seperti ini akan selalu
menjadi density matrices yang valid dan yang lebih penting density matrix yang kamu dapatkan akan merepresentasikan pemilihan acak tersebut dengan
cara yang bermakna. ini digeneralisasi ke pemilihan acak di mana ada lebih dari dua
alternatif. khususnya jika kita memiliki M density matrices yang mungkin dan sebuah vektor probabilitas dengan M entri satu
untuk setiap density matrix dan sebuah sistem disiapkan dalam setiap keadaan yang mungkin dengan probabilitas yang sesuai
maka rata-rata tertimbang dari density matrices tersebut menggambarkan keadaan sistem yang dihasilkan. dan omong-omong ketika
kita menyebutnya kombinasi konveks dari density matrices inilah yang kita maksud. kombinasi konveks hanyalah kombinasi linear
di mana koefisiennya membentuk vektor probabilitas. ini akan selalu menjadi density
matrix dan cara sederhana dan ringkas untuk mengatakannya dalam istilah matematika adalah bahwa himpunan semua density matrices
yang sesuai dengan sistem tertentu adalah himpunan konveks. jadi jika kita memiliki katakanlah m vektor keadaan kuantum
psi 0 hingga s M minus satu beserta probabilitas p 0 hingga p m minus satu yang secara kolektif membentuk
vektor probabilitas dan sistem disiapkan dalam keadaan s k dengan probabilitas PK untuk setiap k maka
keadaan sistem yang dihasilkan digambarkan oleh density matrix yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. khususnya kita tidak merata-ratakan
vektor keadaan kuantum itu sendiri melainkan kita merata-ratakan density matrices yang bersesuaian.
secara umum keadaan seperti ini tidak akan memiliki representasi sebagai vektor keadaan kuantum tunggal
kecuali sesuatu yang sepele terjadi seperti semua vektor keadaan kuantum ekuivalen hingga fase global atau semua kecuali satu dari
probabilitasnya nol. kita tidak akan mendapatkan keadaan kuantum murni dari proses seperti itu melainkan kita akan mendapatkan yang disebut
mixed quantum state di mana ada beberapa ketidakpastian yang melekat. mari kita lihat contoh sederhana.
misalkan kita memiliki sebuah qubit dan dengan probabilitas 1/2 qubit disiapkan dalam keadaan nol dan jika tidak
disiapkan dalam plus State. berikut adalah density matrix yang kita dapatkan dengan cara rata-rata seperti yang telah
saya jelaskan. kita menghitung density matrices yang sesuai dengan dua keadaan yang mungkin, mengalikan dengan probabilitas yang sesuai dan menambahkan
hasilnya. yang kita dapatkan memang density matrix, itu Hermitian, trace-nya sama dengan satu
dan jika kamu menghitung nilai eigen dari matriks ini kamu akan mendapatkan dua bilangan real positif dan kebetulan menjadi dua angka yang seharusnya sudah cukup familiar
bagimu sekarang yaitu cosine kuadrat dari pi per 8 dan sin kuadrat dari pi per 8 atau sekitar 0,85 dan
0,15. tidak ada representasi vektor keadaan kuantum tunggal dari keadaan itu, itu bukan pure state. selanjutnya kita akan melihat satu
density matrix tertentu yang merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum dari qubit tunggal yang dikenal sebagai completely mixed
state. keadaan ini sering muncul sehingga bagus untuk memiliki nama untuknya dan ini juga merupakan contoh yang bagus karena
mengilustrasikan fitur penting dari density matrices. sebenarnya ada completely mixed state yang didefinisikan secara analog untuk setiap
sistem tapi untuk sekarang kita akan fokus pada keadaan ini untuk qubit tunggal hanya untuk menjaga
kesederhanaan. misalkan kita secara acak menetapkan keadaan qubit menjadi keadaan nol atau keadaan satu masing-masing dengan
probabilitas sama dengan 1/2, mirip seperti bit acak seragam. kita bisa menghitung representasi density matrix dari keadaan ini
dengan cara biasa. kita mengambil rata-rata dari dua representasi density matrix dari keadaan tersebut. begini
tampilannya dalam bentuk matriks dan yang kita peroleh adalah matriks identitas dibagi
dua. keadaan ini dikenal sebagai completely mixed state dan pada dasarnya merepresentasikan ketidakpastian yang lengkap atau maksimal
tentang sebuah qubit, sama seperti vektor probabilitas seragam merepresentasikan ketidakpastian maksimal dalam
pengaturan probabilistik klasik. secara umum untuk sistem sembarang, completely mixed state adalah
keadaan yang kita peroleh dengan memilih keadaan basis standar secara seragam dan representasi density matrix-nya akan menjadi
matriks identitas dibagi dengan dimensi atau ekuivalennya jumlah keadaan klasik dari sistem
tersebut. saat ini ini hanya terminologi tapi jika kita mengubah pengaturan sedikit kita akan melihat fitur penting dari
density matrices. khususnya mari kita misalkan kita mengubah prosedur dan sebagai pengganti
keadaan basis standar nol dan satu kita mengganti dengan plus State dan minus State. kali ini kita mulai dengan
ekspresi yang ditampilkan di layar tapi jika kita melalui aritmatikanya kita mendapatkan persis
density matrix yang sama. itu adalah matriks identitas dibagi dua. jadi itu keadaan yang sama seperti sebelumnya yaitu
completely mixed state. ini seperti yang mereka katakan adalah fitur dan bukan bug. kedua prosedur tersebut sebenarnya
berbeda tapi jika yang kamu miliki hanyalah qubit yang dihasilkan tidak ada cara fisik yang mungkin kamu bisa membedakan keduanya
bahkan dalam arti statistik. misalnya jika kamu melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada qubit ini
setelah prosedur pertama dilakukan kamu jelas akan mendapatkan hasil nol dengan probabilitas 1/2 dan hasil satu dengan probabilitas 1/2. tapi kamu juga akan mendapatkan
probabilitas hasil yang persis sama untuk prosedur kedua dan hal yang sama berlaku untuk tes lain yang mungkin kamu
rancang dengan asumsi kamu hanya menguji qubit itu sendiri. secara umum density matrices tidak menggambarkan bagaimana sistem
disiapkan, mereka hanya memberi tahu kamu apa yang akan terjadi jika kamu melakukan sesuatu pada sistem tersebut ke depannya apakah itu melakukan
operasi atau pengukuran dan sebenarnya density matrices sempurna dalam hal
ini. jika dua alternatif yang berbeda menghasilkan density matrix yang sama mereka tidak bisa dibedakan bahkan
secara statistik. tapi jika dua density matrices berbeda maka akan ada cara untuk membedakan keduanya tidak
harus secara definitif tapi dalam arti statistik. ketika kita menggunakan formulasi umum informasi
kuantum informasi klasik pada dasarnya muncul sebagai kasus khusus dan saya akan menjelaskan bagaimana hal itu
WEBVTT
bekerja. khususnya kita akan melihat bagaimana keadaan probabilistik bisa direpresentasikan oleh density
matrices. mari mulai dengan keadaan klasik dimulai dengan contoh
sederhana. berikut adalah representasi density matrix dari keadaan basis standar nol dan satu dari sebuah
qubit. kita mengasosiasikan keadaan-keadaan ini dengan keadaan klasik 0 dan 1 dan jadi kita bisa memikirkan density matrices ini sebagai
merepresentasikan keadaan-keadaan tersebut. itu sangat sederhana dan kita bisa dengan mudah menggeneralisasi
contoh tersebut. jika kita memiliki sistem yang himpunan keadaan klasiknya adalah Sigma maka keadaan klasik a direpresentasikan oleh atau
diasosiasikan dengan density matrix ket-a bra-a. matriks itu memiliki satu satuan tunggal di
entri diagonal yang baris dan kolomnya sesuai dengan keadaan klasik a dan setiap entri lainnya adalah
nol. keadaan probabilistik direpresentasikan oleh kombinasi konveks dari matriks dalam bentuk ini yang natural
mengingat apa yang kita ketahui tentang density matrices dan bagaimana cara kerjanya. khususnya bahwa kombinasi konveks dari density matrices merepresentasikan pemilihan acak atau
probabilistik dari keadaan kuantum. misalnya mari kita misalkan kita
memiliki sistem X yang himpunan keadaan klasiknya mencakup bilangan bulat 0 hingga n minus satu untuk beberapa bilangan bulat positif n.
tentu ada sedikit atau tidak ada kerugian keumuman dalam mengasumsikan bahwa himpunan keadaan klasik kita memiliki bentuk ini. jika kita memiliki
himpunan keadaan klasik yang berbeda kita bisa hanya mengganti nama keadaan klasik dengan cara ini dan seringkali cukup nyaman untuk membuat asumsi bahwa
himpunan keadaan klasik kita terlihat seperti ini sebagian besar karena itu memudahkan untuk menuliskan hal-hal secara eksplisit dalam bentuk
vektor dan matriks. misalkan kita memiliki keadaan probabilistik dari sistem X
yang direpresentasikan oleh vektor probabilitas dengan cara biasa, kita bisa mengasosiasikan keadaan probabilistik ini dengan density
matrix seperti yang ditampilkan di layar. kita mengambil rata-rata tertimbang dari density matrices yang sesuai dengan
berbagai keadaan klasik dan yang kita dapatkan adalah density matrix diagonal. khususnya kita melihat probabilitas-probabilitas
di sepanjang diagonal matriks ini dan setiap entri lainnya sama dengan nol. tentu saja ini adalah density matrix
dan kita berharap itu memang demikian tapi kita juga bisa menarik alasannya secara langsung. itu adalah matriks Hermitian dan trace-nya
sama dengan satu karena probabilitasnya berjumlah satu dan dalam kasus matriks diagonal nilai eigen adalah entri diagonal
dan semuanya non-negatif karena itu adalah probabilitas. perhatikan juga bahwa setiap
density matrix diagonal yang berarti yang entri di luar diagonalnya semuanya nol harus terlihat seperti ini. jadi singkatnya
keadaan probabilistik bisa diasosiasikan dengan density matrices diagonal. perhatikan omong-omong bahwa ini konsisten dengan
interpretasi informal dari entri density matrices yang saya sebutkan di awal pelajaran. khususnya tidak ada yang dalam
superposisi kuantum di sini. itu pada dasarnya hanya keacakan klasik dan dengan demikian semua entri di luar diagonal
adalah nol. sebelumnya dalam seri ini kita membahas teorema spektral dan kita melakukan itu
khusus untuk matriks uniter dalam konteks phase estimation. teorema spektral lebih
umum dari itu namun artinya memberitahu kita sesuatu tentang kelas matriks yang lebih luas daripada hanya matriks uniter.
khususnya berlaku untuk kelas matriks yang disebut matriks normal yang mencakup semua matriks Hermitian serta
matriks uniter. yang akan kita lakukan sekarang adalah melihat pernyataan yang berbeda dari teorema ini, kali ini berfokus hanya pada
matriks positive semi-definite dan kemudian kita akan melihat bahwa itu memberi tahu kita sesuatu yang sangat menarik dan sangat penting tentang density
matrices. misalkan P adalah sembarang matriks positive semi-definite sehingga itu mencakup sembarang density matrix juga maupun sembarang
matriks positive semi-definite yang kebetulan tidak memiliki Trace sama dengan satu. P adalah positive semi-definite sehingga harus
berbentuk persegi atau dengan kata lain N kali n untuk beberapa pilihan N dan kita perlu merujuk ke angka n tersebut jadi biarkan N dipilih
dengan tepat atau cara lain untuk mengatakan semua ini adalah asumsikan P adalah n kali n. apa yang teorema katakan kepada kita dalam kasus ini adalah bahwa
harus ada basis ortonormal dari vektor yang akan kita namai s0 hingga S n minus satu beserta bilangan real
non-negatif Lambda 0 hingga Lambda n minus satu sedemikian sehingga P bisa diekspresikan seperti yang ditampilkan
di sini di layar. dalam kata-kata jika kita mengalikan setiap Lambda K dengan ket-psi-k kali bra-psi-k dan kemudian
menjumlahkan semua K dari 0 sampai n minus satu maka kita akan mendapatkan P. ini disebut dekomposisi spektral
dari P. setiap Lambda K adalah nilai eigen dari P dan setiap psi adalah vektor eigen satuan dari P
yang sesuai dengan nilai eigen tersebut. jika kamu melihat kembali ke pelajaran 7 tentang phase estimation kamu akan menemukan teorema yang serupa
untuk matriks uniter. di sana nilai eigennya adalah bilangan kompleks pada lingkaran satuan daripada bilangan real non-negatif
tapi selain itu idenya sama dan ini sebenarnya hanya dua kasus khusus dari teorema yang lebih umum yang dikenal sebagai
teorema spektral. itu tidak bekerja untuk setiap matriks, kamu perlu matriks untuk berkomutatif dengan
conjugate transpose-nya sendiri dan itulah artinya matriks adalah normal. tapi kita memang selalu memiliki
itu untuk matriks uniter dan matriks positive semi-definite dan untuk matriks Hermitian secara lebih umum di mana
kita selalu akan memiliki nilai eigen real tapi tidak harus yang non-negatif. jadi itulah pernyataan dari
teorema spektral untuk hanya matriks positive semi-definite dan sekarang mari kita lihat apa yang itu katakan kepada kita tentang density
matrices. apa yang itu katakan kepada kita adalah bahwa untuk sembarang density matrix n kali n kita selalu bisa mengekspresikan matriks tersebut sebagai kombinasi konveks
dari n pure states dan lebih jauh lagi kita bisa mengambil n pure states tersebut menjadi
ortogonal. itu mengikuti cukup langsung dari teorema bersama dengan fakta dasar dari aljabar linear yang adalah bahwa
jumlah nilai eigen dari sembarang matriks selalu sama dengan trace dari matriks tersebut. dengan kata lain yang benar-benar kita lakukan di sini adalah
mengganti nama nilai eigen p 0 hingga PN minus satu dan kemudian mengamati bahwa ketika kita melakukan itu dan
mengumpulkan nilai eigen tersebut ke dalam vektor n dimensi kita pasti mendapatkan vektor probabilitas karena semuanya harus non-negatif dan jumlahnya sama dengan
trace dari rho yang adalah satu karena rho adalah density matrix. jadi itu cukup sederhana tapi
secara konseptual sangat fundamental. apa yang itu katakan kepada kita adalah bahwa setiap density matrix, tidak peduli
seberapa rumit tampaknya, bisa muncul dari pertama-tama memilih basis ortonormal dari sistem apapun
yang kita bicarakan dan kemudian secara acak memilih keadaan kuantum dari basis tersebut sesuai dengan beberapa pilihan untuk
WEBVTT
probabilitasnya. jika tidak langsung jelas mengapa itu menarik atau penting, tidak apa-apa tapi kita memang menggunakan
fakta ini sangat sering ketika kita menalar tentang density matrices dan sebenarnya mengekspresikan density matrix tertentu
dengan cara ini seringkali merupakan hal pertama yang kita lakukan ketika kita ingin memahaminya
lebih baik. berikut adalah contohnya. ingat density matrix yang kita temukan sebelumnya di mana kita secara acak memilih antara
keadaan nol dan plus State masing-masing dengan probabilitas 1/2 yang seperti yang kita hitung memiliki density matrix yang
terlihat seperti ini. keadaan nol dan plus state tidak ortogonal sehingga ini bukan
dekomposisi spektral. tapi jika kita menghitung satu yang bisa kita lakukan dengan komputer atau dengan tangan dalam kasus seperti ini maka yang
kita dapatkan adalah ekspresi density matrix kita di mana nilai eigennya adalah angka-angka yang terus muncul dan
di mana vektor eigen yang sesuai bisa dipilih seperti yang ditampilkan di sini di layar dan sekali lagi kita sudah melihat vektor-vektor ini sebelumnya misalnya dalam
konteks permainan CHSH di Pelajaran Empat. jadi itu menarik. menurut
ekspresi aslinya keadaan ini adalah yang kita dapatkan dengan secara seragam memilih antara dua keadaan yaitu keadaan nol dan
plus state. tapi sebenarnya kita mendapatkan density matrix yang persis sama dengan secara acak memilih antara dua pure
states tapi kita sangat sangat berat memihak ke salah satunya sekitar 85% untuk yang pertama dan hanya sekitar 15% untuk
yang kedua. jadi dalam suatu artian sebenarnya ada jauh lebih sedikit keacakan yang melekat pada keadaan itu dari yang awalnya mungkin
terlihat. ada cara geometris yang sangat bagus untuk memikirkan dan memvisualisasikan keadaan kuantum dari qubit tunggal yang dikenal
sebagai Bloch sphere. itu hanya bekerja untuk qubit tunggal. untuk sistem yang memiliki tiga
atau lebih keadaan klasik termasuk dua atau lebih qubit bersamaan itu tidak bekerja lagi. jadi itu memang cukup terbatas tapi
meskipun begitu itu adalah cara yang bagus untuk memikirkan keadaan qubit tunggal. itu bisa diperkenalkan jauh
sejak pelajaran satu dalam seri tentang sistem tunggal tapi sebenarnya tidak begitu penting untuk memahami bagaimana informasi kuantum bekerja dan juga memiliki
hubungan yang sangat bagus dengan density matrices sehingga cocok secara alami dengan pelajaran ini. dan sebenarnya saya akan menjelaskan
dengan cara yang agak berbeda dari yang mungkin paling umum dijelaskan dengan menggunakan density matrices untuk secara efektif
menderivasinya. jadi jika kamu sudah familiar dengan Bloch sphere penjelasan ini mungkin sedikit berbeda dari cara
kamu pertama kali mempelajarinya tapi pada akhirnya tentu saja itu seharusnya ekuivalen. kita akan mulai dengan memikirkan
kemungkinan pure states dari qubit pertama-tama sebagaimana direpresentasikan oleh vektor keadaan
kuantum. hingga fase global setiap vektor keadaan kuantum qubit bisa diekspresikan seperti
yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. untuk lebih tepat kita memiliki dua bilangan real Theta dan fi dan kita akan berpikir
tentang dua angka ini sebagai sudut yang diekspresikan dalam radian. angka pertama Theta adalah antara 0 dan Pi atau ekuivalennya adalah
sudut antara 0 dan 180° dan angka kedua fi adalah antara 0 dan 2 pi termasuk 0 tapi tidak 2
pi. jadi itu adalah sudut apapun antara 0 dan 360°. entri nol dari vektor kita adalah
cosine dari theta per 2 sehingga itu adalah bilangan real antara 0 dan 1 dan khususnya itu pasti non-negatif
dan entri satu dari vektor kita adalah e pangkat i kali fi kali sinus dari theta per 2 dan itu bisa menjadi
bilangan kompleks apapun pada atau di dalam lingkaran satuan kompleks. ini selalu merupakan vektor satuan atau
dengan kata lain merupakan vektor keadaan kuantum yang valid dan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum qubit apapun kita selalu bisa menemukan
vektor dalam bentuk ini yang ekuivalen dengan vektor tersebut hingga fase global. khususnya kita selalu bisa
mengalikan vektor yang diberikan dengan fase global untuk membuat entri nol menjadi bilangan real non-negatif, pilih
Theta apapun yang cocok untuk memberi kita entri tersebut dan kemudian pilih fi untuk mencocokkan entri satu. besarnya entri satu akan
selalu pasti sesuai dengan sinus dari theta per dua berdasarkan asumsi bahwa kita memulai dengan vektor
satuan. sekarang tidak sepenuhnya benar bahwa Theta dan fi secara unik ditentukan oleh vektor keadaan kuantum apapun yang kita mulai
dengan tapi hampir demikian. akan selalu ada nilai unik dari theta antara nol dan Pi yang berlaku
dan biasanya ada nilai unik dari fi yang berlaku tapi dalam dua kasus khusus itu tidak benar. khususnya jika kita memulai dengan
keadaan basis standar maka Theta akan bernilai nol atau pi dan dalam kedua kasus sebenarnya tidak penting apa fi-nya, itu
sama sekali tidak relevan. ketika Theta nol, cosine dari theta per 2 adalah 1 dan sinus dari theta per 2
adalah nol sehingga kita mengalikan e pangkat i kali fi dengan nol sehingga tidak ada bedanya apa fi-nya.
dan jika Theta adalah pi maka kali ini cosine-nya nol dan sinus-nya satu sehingga kita memiliki e pangkat i kali fi kali ket-1 tapi
vektor-vektor tersebut semuanya ekuivalen hingga fase global sehingga sekali lagi tidak penting apa fi-nya. namun jika Theta berada dengan tepat
antara nol dan Pi maka akan selalu ada nilai unik dari fi yang berlaku dan omong-omong kemungkinan
degenerasi dalam nilai fi untuk dua kasus khusus ini akan masuk akal ketika kita melihat gambar geometris dalam
waktu sebentar. sekarang mari hitung density matrix yang diasosiasikan dengan vektor keadaan dalam bentuk yang baru saja kita
identifikasi. jadi ini akan menjadi pure state dari qubit. untuk melakukan ini kita mengalikan vektor
ke conjugate transpose-nya seperti biasa dan di layar adalah ekspresi dari matriks yang kita dapatkan dengan menghitung conjugate
transpose dan melakukan perkalian. sekarang seperti setiap matriks 2x2
ada cara unik untuk mendapatkan matriks ini dengan mengambil kombinasi linear dari Pauli matrices
termasuk matriks identitas. khususnya kita bisa mendapatkan matriks ini dengan memilih koefisien dari
Pauli matrices seperti yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. kita menaruh dua di penyebut karena itu akan membuat
semuanya berjalan dengan baik. tidak ada yang memaksa kita untuk melakukan ini tapi kita bisa dan akan sangat membantu untuk melakukannya. tapi di luar
pilihan kosmetik ini tidak ada kebebasan di sini. ini adalah satu-satunya cara untuk mendapatkan matriks ini dengan mengambil kombinasi linear dari Pauli matrices. itu
karena Pauli matrices termasuk matriks identitas adalah basis untuk ruang vektor dari semua matriks 2x2. satu cara
untuk memeriksa kebenaran ekspresi ini adalah dengan menggunakan beberapa identitas trigonometri dasar dan khususnya jika saya minggir sebentar
di sini kita memiliki beberapa identitas yang akan melakukannya. jadi jika kamu mau, pause video atau
ambil screenshot dan lihat apakah kamu bisa mendapatkan ekspresi kedua dari density matrix di bagian bawah dari yang pertama. jadi singkatnya setiap pure state dari
qubit yang diekspresikan sebagai density matrix bisa ditulis sebagai kombinasi linear dari Pauli matrices seperti yang ditampilkan di
WEBVTT
layar untuk Theta antara 0 dan pi dan fi antara 0 dan 2 pi. perhatikan bahwa kita memiliki persis
degenerasi yang sama seperti sebelumnya yaitu fi tidak relevan ketika Theta bernilai nol atau pi dan kali ini kita sebenarnya bisa
melihat itu lebih jelas karena sinus dari theta adalah nol dalam dua kasus tersebut dan jika tidak maka tidak. perlu dicatat
bahwa dalam rumus ini kita memiliki Theta yang muncul sebagai argumen untuk fungsi sinus dan cosinus daripada Theta per 2 seperti dalam versi vektor keadaan kuantum asli
dan itu karena kita menggunakan identitas trigonometri tersebut yang tiga pertamanya pada dasarnya adalah
penyusunan ulang dari rumus sudut ganda sehingga sudut secara efektif digandakan. dan sekarang kita akhirnya siap untuk
membicarakan Bloch sphere itu sendiri. mari fokus pada tiga koefisien dari Pauli matrices non-identitas
di pembilang dari ekspresi density matrix kita. jadi kita mengabaikan dua di
penyebut dan kita juga mengabaikan matriks identitas karena koefisien pada matriks identitas itu tidak pernah berubah. itu terjadi karena
koefisien tersebut ditentukan oleh trace dari matriks apapun yang kita ekspresikan dan density matrices selalu memiliki Trace sama dengan
satu. sekarang bayangkan kita memiliki tiga sumbu berlabel x, y, dan z yang diorientasikan sesuai dengan
aturan tangan kanan yang disebut dan pertimbangkan titik yang koordinatnya cocok dengan tiga koefisien tersebut dan hanya untuk lebih jelas ini adalah
ruang tiga dimensi biasa yang kita bicarakan di mana koordinatnya selalu bilangan real. koordinat
x sesuai dengan koefisien dari Pauli matrix sigma X di pembilang ekspresi kita yang selalu merupakan bilangan real karena density
matrices adalah Hermitian dan begitu juga untuk y dan z. yang kita temukan adalah bahwa titik yang kita
dapatkan selalu berada di bola satuan atau dengan kata lain bola yang memiliki radius sama dengan
satu. dan khususnya itu adalah titik yang kita dapatkan jika kita mulai dari titik di mana sumbu z positif berpotongan dengan bola
yang bisa kita anggap sebagai Kutub Utara, rotasi ke bawah menuju sumbu x positif sebesar sudut theta dan kemudian
rotasi menuju sumbu y positif atau dengan kata lain ke Timur sebesar sudut fi. dalam konteks ini sudut Theta adalah
yang disebut sudut polar yang mudah diingat karena dimulai dari kutub dan fi disebut sudut
azimut dan bersama dua sudut ini merepresentasikan koordinat bola untuk titik-titik di bola satuan. dan jika
kamu mau kamu juga bisa membiarkan radius bervariasi untuk merepresentasikan titik-titik sembarang dalam ruang tiga dimensi tapi di sini kita fokus pada titik-titik di
bola satuan di mana radius sama dengan satu. kamu juga bisa memikirkan Theta sebagai merepresentasikan lintang kecuali bahwa kita pergi
dari 0 hingga 180° dari Kutub Utara ke kutub selatan daripada plus minus 90° dari khatulistiwa dan fi merepresentasikan
bujur di mana kita pada dasarnya mendefinisikan meridian utama sebagai meridian yang berpotongan dengan sumbu x
positif. jika kamu seperti saya omong-omong dan kesulitan mengingat mana yang lintang dan mana yang bujur mungkin membantu untuk mengingat
bahwa bujur sesuai dengan interval yang lebih panjang yaitu 2 pi dibandingkan dengan
Pi. bagaimanapun titik yang kita peroleh di bola satuan dari vektor keadaan qubit kita s dengan memikirkan koordinat dengan cara ini
adalah representasi Bloch sphere dari keadaan kuantum yang sesuai dengan psi dan ketika kita memikirkan seluruh
bola satuan tiga dimensi dengan cara ini kita mendapatkan Bloch sphere. secara geometris itu hanyalah bola
satuan dalam ruang tiga dimensi biasa tapi sebenarnya itulah geometri dari keadaan
qubit. ada korespondensi satu-ke-satu yang sempurna di sini. setiap pure state dari qubit sesuai dengan titik unik di
bola dan setiap titik di bola merepresentasikan keadaan qubit unik hingga fase global. ketika kita bekerja dengan
vektor keadaan kuantum korespondensi ini memang memiliki nama lain omong-omong. kadang-kadang juga disebut bola Poincaré misalnya
tapi dalam konteks informasi kuantum umumnya disebut sebagai Bloch sphere. perhatikan bahwa kita sekarang bisa melihat
degenerasi dalam sudut fi dengan cukup jelas karena bujur tidak memiliki makna di Kutub Utara dan Selatan. tapi selain
kutub-kutub tersebut setiap titik di Bumi memiliki koordinat unik dalam hal lintang dan bujur dan hal yang sama terjadi di sini. jadi itulah cara
Bloch sphere bekerja secara umum. sekarang mari kita lihat beberapa contoh spesifik dari keadaan qubit dan
di mana mereka berada di Bloch sphere. mari mulai dengan basis standar. ini adalah titik-titik yang kita peroleh
ketika sudut polar Theta nol untuk keadaan nol dan Pi untuk keadaan satu. ini adalah dua kasus di mana
sudut azimut fi tidak relevan seperti yang sudah saya bahas. kita juga bisa mengekspresikan density matrices yang sesuai sebagai kombinasi linear
dari Pauli matrices dengan cara apapun kita simpulkan bahwa dua keadaan ini sesuai dengan Kutub Utara dan
Kutub Selatan dari Bloch sphere. keadaan nol ada di atas dan keadaan satu ada di
bawah. selanjutnya mari cari plus state dan minus state di Bloch sphere. sekali lagi kita bisa memikirkan
vektor keadaan kuantum atau density matrices. untuk vektor keadaan kuantum kali ini sudut polar Theta harus Pi
per 2 agar entri nol menjadi 1 per akar 2. sudut azimut fi harus nol
untuk plus State karena entri satu positif untuk plus State dan harus Pi atau 180° untuk minus State
karena itu negatif dalam kasus tersebut. jadi dua titik ini berada di
khatulistiwa Bloch sphere. plus state berada di mana sumbu x positif berpotongan dengan bola dan minus state ada di sisi yang berlawanan di mana
sumbu x negatif berpotongan dengan bola. ekuivalennya kita juga bisa melihat dari ekspresi Pauli matrix untuk
density matrices yang sesuai bahwa koordinat Y dan Z keduanya nol sedangkan koordinat x adalah positif dan negatif
1. contoh lain adalah basis plus-I minus-I yang mirip dengan basis plus-minus kecuali bahwa kita juga mengalikan
entri satu dengan i unit imajiner. kita melihat plus-I State sebelumnya dalam pelajaran dan minus-I state didefinisikan
dengan cara analog. sudut polar Theta sama dengan untuk plus State dan minus State yaitu Pi per
2 dan kali ini kita perlu memilih sudut azimut fi sehingga kita mendapatkan i dan negatif i daripada 1 dan negatif 1.
dan Pi per 2 dan 3 Pi per 2 adalah pilihan yang tepat untuk membuat itu terjadi. sekali lagi kita juga bisa melihat
deskripsi density matrix dari keadaan-keadaan ini dan hal-hal cukup mirip dengan dua contoh sebelumnya kecuali bahwa kali ini adalah Pauli Y matrix sebagai pengganti
Z atau X. jadi di Bloch sphere dua keadaan ini terletak di mana sumbu y
berpotongan dengan bola dan jika kita membersihkan sedikit kita bisa melihat lebih jelas bagaimana enam keadaan yang baru saja kita bahas
saling berkaitan. hanya untuk satu contoh lagi atau sebenarnya sekelompok contoh pertimbangkan
vektor keadaan qubit yang muncul sebelumnya dan di Pelajaran Empat di mana entri nol adalah cosine dari alpha untuk beberapa bilangan real Alpha dan entri
WEBVTT
satunya adalah sinus dari alpha. kita omong-omong bisa membatasi perhatian kita pada nilai alpha antara nol dan Pi karena nilai
alpha lainnya akan memberi kita vektor yang ekuivalen hingga fase global dengan yang di mana Alpha berada dalam rentang
ini. jika kita menghitung density matrices yang diasosiasikan dengan keadaan-keadaan ini yang diekspresikan sebagai kombinasi linear dari Pauli matrices
kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. perhitungan tersebut tidak ditampilkan di sini tapi itulah yang seharusnya kamu
dapatkan jika kamu melaluinya dan yang kita temukan adalah bahwa keadaan-keadaan ini membentuk apa yang disebut lingkaran besar yang melewati
kutub-kutub. khususnya dimulai dari Kutub Utara ketika Alpha nol turun sepanjang meridian utama dan
mencapai Kutub Selatan ketika Alpha adalah pi per 2 dan kemudian kembali ke Kutub Utara di sisi berlawanan dari bola ketika Alpha berkisar dari pi per 2 ke
Pi. dan itu semua masuk akal karena pertama, vektor-vektor ini adalah vektor real sehingga bagian imajinernya selalu nol dan kedua,
sudut Alpha secara efektif digandakan di Bloch sphere dan sekali lagi itu bisa dijelaskan dengan penggunaan
rumus sudut ganda. kita telah melihat bahwa Bloch sphere menyediakan representasi geometris yang sangat bagus untuk pure states dari
qubit di mana setiap titik di bola sesuai dengan pure state unik dari qubit dan sebaliknya.
ketika kita menyebutnya Bloch ball kita berbicara tentang semua titik di Bloch sphere serta titik-titik
yang terkandung di dalamnya. titik-titik di bagian dalam Bloch ball juga sesuai dengan keadaan qubit
khususnya keadaan yang bukan pure states. jadi dengan kata lain ini adalah keadaan qubit yang bisa direpresentasikan oleh density matrices tapi tidak oleh vektor keadaan qubit.
aspek mendasar dari Bloch ball dan cara titik-titik interior merepresentasikan keadaan yang tidak murni adalah bahwa
kombinasi konveks dari titik-titik di dalam Bloch ball sesuai dengan kombinasi konveks dari density matrices.
secara intuitif ini berarti bahwa geometrinya terus bekerja dengan sempurna bahkan di dalam Bloch
ball. mari kita lihat beberapa contoh dimulai dengan titik pusat Bloch ball yang merepresentasikan
completely mixed state. completely mixed state diperoleh dengan merata-ratakan keadaan nol dan satu yang konsisten dengan fakta
bahwa pusat bola berada tepat di tengah antara Kutub Utara dan Kutub Selatan dan sebenarnya itu adalah tengah-tengah antara dua titik antipodal apapun seperti
plus state dan minus state serta plus-I state dan minus-I state. titik-titik antipodal di Bloch sphere selalu sesuai dengan
pure states yang ortogonal dan apa yang ini ungkapkan atau cerminkan adalah bahwa kita selalu bisa menulis completely mixed state
sebagai rata-rata antara dua pure states qubit ortogonal apapun. cara lain untuk melihat ini adalah dengan
memikirkan representasi Pauli matrix dari completely mixed state. untuk membuat ini berhasil kita harus menetapkan
koefisien pada ketiga Pauli matrices non-identitas menjadi nol dan jadi titik yang sesuai di dalam
Bloch ball berada tepat di tengah di titik asal. dan omong-omong memikirkan representasi Pauli matrix dari density
matrices seperti ini sebenarnya cukup jelas bahwa kombinasi konveks dari titik-titik Bloch ball sesuai dengan kombinasi konveks
dari density matrices. jika kita mengambil rata-rata atau rata-rata tertimbang dari density matrices dan
mengekspresikan segalanya dalam hal kombinasi linear dari Pauli matrices maka tentu saja kita hanya merata-ratakan titik-titik yang sesuai karena semuanya
linear dalam tiga koefisien tersebut. untuk satu contoh lagi mari pertimbangkan rata-rata dari keadaan nol
dan plus state yang kita lihat sebelumnya dalam pelajaran. kita menghitung representasi density matrix yang ditampilkan di
layar dan kita memiliki bahwa titiknya berada di bagian dalam Bloch ball di tengah-tengah antara keadaan nol dan plus
state. kita juga melihat bahwa kita bisa mengekspresikan density matrix ini dengan cara yang berbeda berdasarkan dekomposisi spektralnya dan
sekali lagi itu konsisten dengan diagram dan contoh-contoh sebelumnya. dan itu mengakhiri
diskusi tentang Bloch sphere dan Bloch ball. orang sering bertanya apakah ada Bloch sphere atau Bloch ball untuk sistem yang memiliki
tiga atau lebih keadaan klasik dan jawabannya yang sayangnya adalah tidak terlalu. kita selalu bisa memikirkan
keadaan kuantum suatu sistem dalam istilah geometris yang mirip dengan Bloch ball dan kita akan mendapatkan benda konveks dalam ruang vektor real
tapi jika kita memiliki tiga atau lebih keadaan klasik itu tidak akan berbentuk bola. misalnya jika kita memiliki
tepat tiga keadaan klasik atau qutrit singkatnya kita akan mendapatkan benda konveks dalam ruang
delapan dimensi tapi titik-titik ekstrem dari benda tersebut yang sesuai dengan pure states kuantum dari qutrit hanya akan berbentuk
empat dimensi. jika kamu bisa memvisualisasikan pengambilan manifold empat dimensi dalam ruang delapan dimensi dan entah bagaimana membungkusnya untuk mendapatkan benda konveks
dan kamu menemukan itu sebagai cara yang membantu untuk memikirkan qutrit maka lebih bagimu. menarik untuk
dipikirkan tapi itu bukan bola, itu lebih rumit dari itu. di bagian terakhir pelajaran kita akan secara singkat membahas
bagaimana density matrices bekerja untuk beberapa sistem. density matrices bisa merepresentasikan keadaan beberapa sistem dan ini
bekerja dengan cara yang sepenuhnya analog dengan vektor keadaan kuantum. khususnya seperti yang kita miliki dalam formulasi sederhana informasi
kuantum kita bisa melihat beberapa sistem bersama seolah-olah mereka adalah satu sistem majemuk
tunggal. kali ini baik baris maupun kolom dari density matrices yang merepresentasikan keadaan beberapa sistem
ditempatkan sesuai dengan produk kartesian dari himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem individual. misalnya kita bisa mempertimbangkan
representasi density matrix dari empat Bell states yang kita peroleh persis seperti yang kita lakukan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum
lainnya sebelumnya dalam pelajaran dengan mengalikan vektor keadaan ke conjugate transpose-nya dan hasilnya ditampilkan di
layar. pada dasarnya tidak ada yang baru di level konseptual meskipun kita akan segera melihat bahwa ada beberapa
hal baru yang bisa kita lakukan dengan density matrices untuk beberapa sistem. gagasan tentang independensi dan
korelasi terbawa dari vektor keadaan kuantum ke density matrices dan khususnya kita menemukan bahwa tensor products
dari density matrices merepresentasikan independensi antara sistem. kita menggunakan terminologi yang sama yang
kita gunakan untuk vektor keadaan kuantum. misalnya jika kita memiliki sistem X yang disiapkan dalam keadaan rho dan sistem y
yang secara independen disiapkan dalam keadaan Sigma maka keadaan dari pasangan XY bersama diberikan oleh tensor product
dari rho dan sigma. kita sebut ini product state dan ini digeneralisasi secara natural ke lebih dari dua
sistem. density matrices yang tidak bisa diekspresikan sebagai product states merepresentasikan korelasi antara sistem dan
bagian itu mirip dengan vektor keadaan kuantum tapi ternyata ada jenis korelasi yang berbeda yang bisa muncul ketika kita menggunakan density matrices bahkan untuk
dua sistem saja. sebaliknya sebenarnya hanya ada satu jenis korelasi yang bisa kita miliki untuk vektor keadaan kuantum dan
itu adalah entanglement. untuk mengatakan ini dengan cara lain, korelasi dan entanglement adalah sinonim untuk vektor keadaan kuantum tapi
WEBVTT
itu tidak benar untuk density matrices. di sini hal-hal lebih menarik. misalnya kita bisa menggambarkan
keadaan klasik yang berkorelasi dengan density matrices. berikut adalah contoh dari density matrix yang merepresentasikan bit acak klasik
yang dibagi antara Alice dan Bob. mereka selalu memiliki keadaan klasik yang sama yaitu nol atau satu dan probabilitasnya adalah
1/2 untuk setiap kemungkinan. ini bukan entangled state. entanglement bersifat non-klasik tapi
itu adalah correlated state. contoh lain terhubung dengan gagasan tentang ensemble keadaan kuantum
yang bisa kamu pikirkan sebagai distribusi probabilitas atas himpunan terbatas keadaan kuantum. khususnya mari bayangkan bahwa
kita memiliki M density matrices rho nol hingga rho M minus satu semuanya merepresentasikan kemungkinan keadaan dari sistem tertentu
beserta probabilitas untuk menarik masing-masing. jika kita mau kita bisa menghitung rata-rata tertimbang dari density matrices ini
dengan mengambil kombinasi konveks dari mereka tapi itu sebenarnya tidak akan memberi tahu kita apa keadaan individual itu atau apa
probabilitasnya. yang bisa kita lakukan sebagai gantinya dan cukup berguna untuk melakukan ini terkadang adalah mempertimbangkan density
matrix dalam bentuk yang ditampilkan di sini di layar. ini adalah keadaan dari dua sistem di mana sistem pertama memiliki satu keadaan klasik
untuk setiap alternatif dan kita mengambil rata-rata tertimbang dari M product states di mana keadaan dari sistem pertama
selalu klasik dan pada dasarnya melabeli mana dari m keadaan yang kita miliki untuk sistem
kedua. jika tidak jelas persis mengapa kita ingin memikirkan keadaan seperti ini, tidak apa-apa. itu hanya contoh dari
jenis korelasi di mana sistem pertama selalu klasik dan sistem kedua bisa berada dalam keadaan
kuantum. kategori ketiga dari keadaan yang mungkin berkorelasi adalah himpunan yang disebut separable
states. dalam istilah sederhana ini adalah kombinasi konveks dari product states dan pada dasarnya merepresentasikan keadaan kuantum
di mana setiap korelasi antara sistem adalah korelasi klasik. satu cara untuk memikirkan
keadaan seperti ini adalah bahwa kita membuat pemilihan probabilistik untuk angka K dan kemudian secara independen menyiapkan dua
sistem dalam keadaan kuantum yang bisa bergantung pada pilihan K ini. yang mungkin paling menarik tentang
keadaan dalam bentuk ini adalah bahwa inilah sebenarnya cara kita mendefinisikan entanglement dalam istilah matematika. khususnya entanglement adalah
didefinisikan sebagai kurangnya separabilitas. jadi jika kamu memiliki density matrix dan tidak mungkin untuk mengekspresikannya dalam bentuk
seperti ini maka menurut definisi itu adalah entangled. saya menyinggung hal ini kembali di Pelajaran Empat dan di sini ada dalam
detail yang lebih lengkap. omong-omong bisa sangat sulit untuk mengetahui apakah density matrix tertentu merepresentasikan keadaan yang entangled
bahkan dengan bantuan komputer. secara matematis dan komputasi entanglement adalah
sebenarnya cukup rumit. saya menyebutkan di awal pelajaran bahwa ada sesuatu yang sangat penting yang bisa kita lakukan dengan density matrices dan
itu adalah menggambarkan keadaan bagian terisolasi dari sistem bahkan ketika mereka berkorelasi dan mungkin terjerat dengan sistem
lain. istilah reduced state sering digunakan dalam konteks ini dan sebagai contoh sederhana kita akan menghitung reduced
states untuk qubit individual yang membentuk ebit. untuk lebih tepat, misalkan
Alice dan Bob berbagi ebit. ALICE memegang qubit A, Bob memegang qubit B dan bersama-sama dua qubit ini berada dalam keadaan phi
plus. dan pertanyaan yang akan kita jawab adalah apa keadaan qubit A milik Alice dalam
isolasi. tentu saja kita bisa mengajukan pertanyaan yang sama untuk qubit Bob tapi mudah untuk menjawab pertanyaan tersebut begitu kita tahu jawabannya untuk yang ini.
sekarang mungkin tergoda untuk mengatakan bahwa kita tidak bisa menggambarkan keadaan qubit Alice secara terpisah karena itu
terjerat dengan qubit Bob yang mungkin entah bagaimana melarang kita untuk menggambarkan atau bahkan memikirkan keadaan A dalam
isolasi. tapi ini salah. memang benar bahwa kita tidak bisa menggambarkan keadaan A dengan vektor keadaan
kuantum karena seperti yang akan kita lihat itu bukan pure state. tapi setiap sistem memiliki keadaan pada momen tertentu yang bisa
digambarkan oleh density matrix apakah itu terjerat dengan sistem lain atau tidak. sebagai eksperimen pikiran hanya untuk membantu
kita melihat apa jawabannya, misalkan Bob memutuskan untuk mengambil qubit-nya dan pergi ke bintang-bintang dan dia tidak pernah terdengar lagi.
tapi bayangkan bahwa di suatu tempat dalam perjalanannya dia memutuskan untuk melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada
qubit-nya. nah kita tahu cara menghitung probabilitas baginya untuk mendapatkan dua kemungkinan hasil dan kita juga tahu apa
keadaan A yang akan terjadi untuk setiap kemungkinan hasil dan hal-hal tersebut dirangkum dalam tabel ini. khususnya dengan probabilitas 1/2
A akan tersisa dalam keadaan nol dan dengan probabilitas 1/2 A akan tersisa dalam keadaan satu dan jadi seperti yang dibahas sebelumnya dalam
pelajaran ini hal itu meninggalkan A dalam completely mixed state dan oleh karena itu itulah jawabannya.
sekarang kamu mungkin keberatan dan mengatakan bahwa ini bergantung pada fakta bahwa
Bob memutuskan untuk mengukur qubit-nya dan asumsi bahwa dia melakukan ini adalah bagian dari cerita yang membawa kita ke jawaban ini. tapi
jika Bob berjarak tahun cahaya jauhnya pada saat dia mengukur, tidak ada yang dia lakukan yang mungkin memiliki pengaruh pada eksperimen
apapun yang Alice mungkin putuskan untuk lakukan pada qubit-nya, jika tidak kita akan memiliki komunikasi yang lebih cepat dari
cahaya. jadi qubit Alice berada dalam completely mixed state terlepas dari apakah Bob
mengukur atau tidak. saya harus memperjelas pada titik ini bahwa gagasan tentang reduced state dan cara mereka didefinisikan sebenarnya tidak memiliki ketergantungan pada relativitas
atau ketidakmungkinan komunikasi yang lebih cepat dari cahaya. ini hanya cara untuk menjelaskannya dengan harapan dalam istilah yang intuitif.
pada kenyataannya ada definisi matematis yang akan kita lihat dalam konteks yang lebih umum dalam beberapa saat. itu konsisten dengan jawaban ini
dan kebetulan dengan ketidakmungkinan komunikasi yang lebih cepat dari cahaya dan tidak ada
definisi lain yang bisa konsisten dengan informasi kuantum sebagaimana yang kita ketahui. sekarang mari pertimbangkan reduced states dalam
generalisasi yang lebih besar. misalkan kita memiliki sepasang sistem A dan B, tidak harus qubit, yang bersama-sama berada dalam pure state
yang direpresentasikan oleh vektor keadaan kuantum s. sekali lagi kita akan fokus pada reduced state dari sistem A dan untuk melakukan
ini akan sangat membantu untuk memikirkan keadaan klasik dari sistem B. jadi mari biarkan gamma menjadi himpunan
keadaan klasik dari B seperti yang telah kita bahas sebelumnya misalnya kembali di pelajaran dua dari seri ini.
ada koleksi unik dari vektor phi-b untuk setiap b dalam Gamma yang ekspresi dari s yang ditampilkan di
layar adalah benar dan khususnya ada rumus sederhana untuk vektor-vektor ini. kita hanya perlu mengalikan vektor s dengan
tensor product dari matriks identitas yang sesuai dengan sistem A dengan bra-b untuk b apapun yang kita minati
apa yang kita lakukan di sini pada dasarnya adalah mempersiapkan diri untuk menghitung apa yang akan terjadi jika kita melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada B dan sekali lagi ini dibahas di pelajaran dua dari
WEBVTT
seri. misalkan kita memang melakukan pengukuran basis standar pada B. setiap kemungkinan hasil akan muncul
dengan probabilitas sama dengan norma Euclidean kuadrat dari vektor phi-b yang sesuai dan dikondisikan pada mendapatkan
hasil tertentu B kita menormalisasi vektor phi-B untuk menentukan keadaan yang dihasilkan dari
A. mengikuti alasan yang sama seperti dalam contoh ebit dari beberapa saat lalu kita mendapatkan ekspresi yang ditampilkan di
layar untuk reduced state dari A sebagai density matrix dan omong-omong norma kuadrat di penyebut berasal dari
mengalikan vektor yang dinormalisasi ke conjugate transpose-nya sehingga kita mendapatkan norma Euclidean dua kali di
penyebut. norma Euclidean kuadrat saling menghapus dan kita tersisa dengan ekspresi yang cukup sederhana.
dan sebenarnya jika kita substitusikan rumus kita untuk phi-B yang berlaku untuk setiap B kita mendapatkan rumus untuk reduced
state dari sistem A dalam hal deskripsi density matrix dari pure state yang kita mulai yaitu ket-psi
bra-psi. jadi ini adalah rumus kita untuk reduced state dari sistem A dengan asumsi bahwa sistem majemuk AB dimulai dalam
pure state psi. tapi kita juga bisa menggunakan rumus ini lebih umum. khususnya misalkan
keadaan AB diberikan oleh beberapa density matrix rho yang bisa mengambil bentuk ket-psi bra-psi untuk beberapa vektor keadaan kuantum
s tapi tidak harus demikian. mengikuti pada dasarnya dari linieritas bahwa reduced state dari A adalah
ditentukan oleh rumus yang sama seperti yang kita miliki untuk pure states kecuali bahwa kita mengganti density matrix rho apapun yang kita
inginkan. sebagai notasi singkat, cukup umum kita menyatakan reduced state ini dengan nama apapun yang kita gunakan untuk
density matrix rho dalam kasus ini tapi kita menempatkan subskript yang menunjukkan sistem yang kita fokuskan. jadi rho dengan
subskript A berarti reduced state dari A ketika sistem majemuk berada dalam keadaan rho. superskrip juga terkadang digunakan
sebagai pengganti subskript. itu pada dasarnya hanya preferensi pribadi dan artinya sama.
kita telah fokus pada sistem A hanya untuk kesederhanaan tapi kita juga bisa mendapatkan reduced state dari sistem B
secara analog tapi di mana rumusnya diadaptasi dengan cara yang natural. semuanya simetris di sini, kita
pada dasarnya hanya menukar peran A dan B dan khususnya jumlahnya berkisar atas keadaan klasik A kali ini
daripada B dan dalam rumus di layar kita mengasumsikan himpunan keadaan klasik dari A disebut
Sigma. semua ini digeneralisasi dengan cara yang cukup langsung ke tiga atau lebih sistem. misalnya jika kita memiliki tiga
sistem A, B, dan C yang secara kolektif berada dalam keadaan yang digambarkan oleh density matrix rho maka kita bisa mendapatkan
reduced state dari pasangan A bersama dengan rumus yang ditampilkan di sini serta keadaan dari sistem ketiga sendiri
yang merupakan rumus kedua. dan kamu bisa mempertimbangkan kombinasi lain dan menggeneralisasikan ini ke berapa pun sistem yang kamu inginkan. jumlahnya selalu diambil atas
himpunan keadaan klasik dari sistem yang diabaikan dan polanya selalu sama dengan density
matrix yang kita mulai dengan diapit antara tensor product dari matriks identitas dan bra serta ket yang sesuai dengan keadaan basis standar
untuk mengakhiri pelajaran saya akan mengatakan sedikit lagi tentang definisi yang baru saja kita bahas. operasi pada density
matrices yang menggambarkan reduced states memiliki nama dan itu disebut partial trace. untuk dua sistem A dan B,
partial Trace atas B dan partial Trace atas A didefinisikan di sini di layar. ini adalah rumus yang persis sama
yang kita lihat beberapa saat lalu dan sekarang kita hanya memikirkannya sebagai fungsi dari rho dan memberinya
nama. namanya terlihat seperti trace kecuali ada subskript yang memberi tahu kita sistem mana yang sedang dihapus
atau dengan kata lain sistem mana yang merupakan himpunan keadaan klasiknya yang kita jumlahkan dan diapit antara bra dan
ket. ketika kita mengambil partial trace dari rho atas B misalnya yang digambarkan oleh rumus pertama kita kadang-kadang mengatakan bahwa
B di-trace out dan begitu juga untuk A. secara intuitif melakukan trace out suatu
sistem hanya berarti kita membuangnya atau mengabaikannya saja. itulah satu cara untuk mendefinisikan partial
trace dan cara ekuivalen lainnya adalah dengan mengatakan bahwa pemetaan-pemetaan ini adalah pemetaan linear unik yang memenuhi
rumus yang ditampilkan di sini di sebelah kanan. khususnya jika kita memiliki tensor product dari dua matriks M dan N, misalkan
saja, dan kita melakukan partial Trace atas sistem pertama maka yang kita dapatkan adalah trace dari matriks pertama M dikalikan dengan
matriks kedua dan kondisinya simetris ketika kita melakukan trace atas sistem kedua. tidak setiap matriks yang kita lakukan
partial trace adalah tensor product seperti ini tapi setiap matriks bisa diekspresikan sebagai kombinasi linear dari
tensor products dan kita bisa menentukan partial Trace dari kondisi-kondisi ini bersama dengan fakta bahwa ini adalah fungsi
linear. dan inilah mengapa itu disebut partial trace. definisi ekuivalen ini bisa
sangat membantu karena kita sering bisa menggunakannya daripada rumus asli. berikut adalah contoh yang
mengilustrasikan ini. misalkan kita memiliki sepasang qubit A dalam keadaan yang density matrix-nya ditampilkan di sini di
layar. ini kebetulan merupakan contoh correlated state di mana A berada dalam keadaan nol atau keadaan satu masing-masing
dengan probabilitas 1/2. jadi kita bisa memikirkan A sebagai klasik. jika A berada dalam keadaan nol maka
B juga begitu dan jika A berada dalam keadaan satu maka B berada dalam plus state. jika kita ingin tahu apa reduced state dari A
kita lakukan trace out B dan jika kita menggunakan rumus kedua dari definisi ekuivalen bersama dengan linieritas maka kita bisa
menghitung ini dengan cukup mudah. khususnya trace dari ket-0 bra-0 adalah satu begitu juga trace dari ket-plus bra-
plus sehingga faktor tensor tersebut menghilang dan kita tersisa dengan completely mixed state. dengan cara yang serupa kita bisa menghitung
reduced state dari B dengan melakukan trace out A. kali ini adalah faktor tensor pertama yang kita lakukan trace-nya sehingga
kita menggunakan rumus pertama dari definisi ekuivalen dan kita tersisa dengan 1/2 kali ket-0 bra-0 ditambah 1/2 kali ket-
plus bra-plus atau dengan kata lain density matrix yang sama yang muncul beberapa kali sebelumnya. kamu akan mendapatkan persis
hasil yang sama jika kamu menggunakan rumus dari definisi pertama tapi ini adalah cara yang jauh lebih mudah untuk melakukannya. ini semua digeneralisasi ke tiga atau lebih
sistem tapi untuk video ini saya akan berhenti di sini dan membiarkan ini untuk kamu pertimbangkan sendiri. dan itulah akhirnya untuk pelajaran ini yang
memperkenalkan density matrices dan menggambarkan dasar-dasar cara kerjanya. kita juga membahas Bloch sphere
serta berbagai jenis korelasi dan gagasan tentang reduced state dari sebuah sistem. semoga kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran berikutnya yang membahas tentang channels yang merupakan pemetaan linear dari density matrices ke density matrices yang
menggambarkan operasi pada sistem selamat tinggal sampai
WEBVTT
menggambarkan operasi pada sistem. sampai jumpa lagi
di lain waktu